well how about this now sacrifices are
meant to be sacrifices here locally
there's one guy
who is willing to risk it all john
treach has a story
of an extraordinary display of
dedication and faith and fundamental
beliefs
he's an ultra competitor with the
ultimate conviction
far more impressive than his fastball is
his fate i didn't really think twice
about it i knew i was keeping shabbos
and i was going to be orthodox and i
also knew i was going to play baseball
so the mix of the two was never really a
thought it was just kind of the way i
was brought up and the way that i want
to carry myself ellie kligman is hitting
over 500
he's thrown no hitters and he can play
any position on the field
until the sun sets on friday the 18 year
old is an observant jew
and a college baseball prospect but
between sundown on friday and sundown on
saturday he respects the sabbath
a devotion superseding the diamond i
don't think there's really a role model
for
in terms of what i'm doing with the
jewish and the baseball the closest
thing is sandy kofax obviously but
he only did it one time mark kligman has
manifested so much joy through baseball
he passed it on to his sons and now
coaches them but he's most proud that
they give the beloved game
the take sign for the torah that's every
parent's dream right to
hopefully lead by example to your
children and in the way that you think
is the right way to live and that they
see
the value in that and they espouse it
for themselves now the challenge is
convincing a college baseball program
where scholarships are at a premium to
gamble on a las vegas who can't play on
friday nights or saturday afternoons
simran memorial's coach cautions
colleges not to swing and miss
he can pitch he can hit he can run he
can feel he can throw you know he can do
it so
i don't see why anybody at the next
level wouldn't want to give that a shot
ellie kligman could be the first
observant jew in division one baseball
history
and his best position is principled i
think that
if i can show people that i don't have
to bend in my faith and i can still be a
major league baseball player division 1
baseball player
or however i take it i just want to show
people that you can do it
john treach 8 sports now